it all happened so quickly but after
months of delays and protests the 2020
budget drafted last year by former prime
minister Saud Harry Lee's government has
finally been ratified the biggest
challenges facing Lebanon's new
government is a near collapsing economy
it says it's priority is to introduce a
financial rescue plan
these are exceptional circumstances
nothing is normal in Lebanon today and
the complexity of dictate we act with
logic while the bill was adopted by a
majority of 49 vote some MPs didn't
attend with a number of opposition
members calling the vote
unconstitutional if it's a necessity to
adopt the budget then it can be a
priority to return or postpone it until
the government receives a vote of
confidence on the new cabinet first the
budget usually ends at the end of
January so I insisted the vote must be
held now but this doesn't mean
Parliament doesn't have the right to
legislate even if there is no government
outside parliament several people were
injured in protests against the vote
security forces used tear gas in
response to some who threw rocks at them
with security setup protesters failed to
stop politicians from entering
Parliament to vote on this controversial
budget or was meant to take two days -
just a few hours with MPs eager to bring
in these economic reforms as soon as
possible but some are calling it a sham
many argue the budget isn't a true
reflection of the current state of the
economy which has deteriorated further
since nationwide protests started in
October against corruption and the
mismanagement of public funds the new
government will be going into the new
year with the bull at the budget of the
old government so it's really very
absurd and surrealistic and we are
definitely against it but unfortunately
because of the first full way that the
protesters were treated we couldn't stop
the session from happening
last week newly appoint
finance minister Ozzie Wesley said that
four to five billion dollars of foreign
loans are urgently needed to buy basics
such as wheat medicine and fuel for the
coming year this year's budget includes
further cuts to government spending but
it's not clear if this among other
economic changes will be enough to meet
the demands of millions of Lebanese
sorry faded al Jazeera fatal